(birds chirping)
(dog barks)
(radio static)
(sirens wailing)
(intense music)
(light music)
- Most people don't realize
that we're losing a
generation to violence.
Kids in this area are in danger every day,
even going to school.
I mean, literally thousands
are being shot every year.
Hundreds dying from gun
violence, it's senseless.
You can look in their
eyes and see hopelessness.
They don't believe they're
gonna live to see 21, 25.
So they don't plan for a future,
so violence is cool because in their mind
they're gonna be gone anyway.
I realize they need
somebody in the community
besides the gang, that believes in them.
(light music)
(birds chirping)
(dog barking)
My mom brought me into Chicago
when I was two weeks old,
and we've been here ever since.
Eight kids, 15 grandkids.
I have my family all around me.
15 years ago, my daughter Ayesha was 13.
She had nine friends, girls and boys,
and I saw 'em running up and
down the street and I was like,
what they gonna do next?
They're young people, they need
stuff to keep them occupied.
So when they're out in the community
and they're around the
kids that are in gangs,
well then they got the next thing.
I knew they were at that stage,
and I wanted to give them a safe place
away from all that, so I had an epiphany.
I went out there and I
brought 'em into my house.
Hey.
- Hey Miss Diane.
- How you are now?
- Good.
- They told me in those
first few hours, you know,
"I'm failing in school, I need help."
Or, "My dad's gone and my mom's on drugs."
You know, I'm like, I'm in shock.
From there I just
started getting involved.
I start sitting with them and listening.
In the next couple of days there were kids
started knocking on my
door that I didn't know,
and they were saying,
"Are you Miss Diane?"
And I'm like, "Yeah."
And they're like, "So and
so said you could help me."
"I wanna go back to school."
And then the next day
there were five and six,
and then they were saying, "I
wanna get out of the gang."
Then homeless kids were
at my door late at night,
and I honestly didn't
know what I was doing,
I just wanted to do it.
You want to try another, find a job?
What you trying to do?
- I feel I could get a job any time.
- Well, why you haven't though?
You 18 now, right?
So, it's time.
- It is time right now.
- I was worried about
you there for a minute,
'cause there was too much going on.
It seemed like you was angry
about it too, but you good now.
Yeah.
(light music)
This is 119th Street, one
of the most violent areas,
or I'd say the most violent
area in our community.
At first it makes you want to run,
like nothing's gonna change.
Just get out, just go do something else,
and then you go, no.
If we leave, then what?
I mean,
I can't do everything, but
I can do what I can do.
When you live on a block with 10 houses
and there's five or six
who have lost people
to gun violence, then it
affects the whole neighborhood,
and so I really wanted to help.
(light instrumental music)
Kids Off the Block, KOB, is
an organization unto itself.
During the school months,
we provide after school programming,
which consists of the tutoring,
and the mentoring and workshops.
Then in the summer months,
violence heats up a lot.
I saw a need, and there was a
vacant lot across the street,
so I turned it into a basketball court.
Go play Mariano.
Oh, he made it! (clapping)
That's crazy.
When the kids are playing
basketball, nothing else matters,
and that's just the truth.
It's a powerful thing.
It literally brings boys together
who are in different gangs,
who are in different cliques.
They play on the court
together, or they eat together,
or they laugh together, so
that's what it's there for.
(light instrumental music)
We estimated that over 3,000 young people
have been impacted or
come through the program.
It became so many reasons
to come to KOB instead of the gang.
So we became a force.
- [Man] Three, two, one.
Let's get involved here.
(whistle blows)
- When I hear that someone's
been shot or killed,
it drains you.
I wanted to do something that
would shock my community,
let the young people see
they're losing their friends to violence,
and that's how the memorial started.
Those young people on those
stones, somebody loved them.
They belonged to people,
they're not just names;
they were actually living
life, and they're gone.
It makes you think how
fragile life is for all of us.
(light instrumental music)
There are 791 stones, and we
still have 421 names there.
Every one of them over
there is under 24 years old.
I've seen two gang members
literally come to the memorial,
and go out and get a job,
and go back to school.
(laughs)
Seriously, the next day.
(light instrumental music)
(birds chirping)
Today we're expanding.
We actually have a space
next door in a building,
and we can get out of my house.
The space isn't ready yet,
but I know what it's gonna
look like, so I'm excited.
Here will be our computer lab.
Computers and printers, and desks.
Here will be our music
studio right in the middle,
and over there on the side
will be our clothing design program.
They need lifetime career skills,
and for us to able to give
them that will take the power,
the violence, the guns,
the gangs, all of that out.
- Miss Diane brought
peace to the neighborhood.
I used to get like in
trouble all the time.
I probably woulda like,
gotten into gangs and stuff,
but Miss Diane told me just to be myself.
Be a leader, not a follower.
- If it wasn't for Miss Diane,
I honestly wouldn't know where I'd be at,
'cause I've been through a lot.
She always been there for me.
- Be careful out here.
- Miss Diane has done a
lot for this community.
From feeding, to clothing,
to housing, to mentoring.
Me, myself, I call her the
Big Mama of this generation.
- How you doing, Mama?
- How are you?
- What you're doing makes a
difference in the community,
and each and every mother
who lost their child.
- She doesn't back off and give in easy;
if she has an idea,
she'll stop at nothing to make it happen,
and that's what she does.
(light instrumental music)
- It was kinda rough around here
before she started Kids Off the Block.
She always looking out.
(light instrumental music)
- [Diane] I don't think a
kid should have to be worried
that they can't walk their own street.
A kid should be worried
about his bubblegum rapper.
A 17-year-old should be
worried about prom, graduating.
African American youth are not the enemy,
and it's people like
myself who are out here,
who are fighting every day
to change that perception,
and we're gonna do it.
We might not have big money,
corporations and all that,
but never doubt people like us,
'cause we'll find a
way because we live it.
Stop judging our young people.
Give them the same opportunities
that everybody else gets,
'cause I guarantee you
you'll find some geniuses.
Just give them the opportunity.
My goal is for Kids Off the Block
to be in every city in this nation,
and we're working on that.
(light instrumental music)
I've been doing this for 15
years, and I'm not stopping.
(light instrumental music)